so you and chase finally went public
but i feel like i knew this before the
world knew
we're horrible liars
i mean why did you wait to sort of go
public was it because you just wanted
to keep things private at first and yeah
i think so i mean
i think the show coming out was already
a pretty big life
change and we're also you know
just starting the whole quarantine
process
and that's a huge life change and you
know going through a global pandemic
i think we were just wanting to kind of
give it some time and enjoy it
while it's you know new and and fresh
and just kind of keep that to ourselves
and then you know it's also one of those
things where we're just like
at some point you're just like
yeah let's share it because it's it's
like yeah it is
we're dating and people people were
already speculating like people
people knew people knew before we said
anything
so is it is it love
oh i like how much you're smiling right
now that's so cute
yeah yeah it's it's really cool um
love is tight and um it's cool to
it's cool to share this experience with
your favorite people
and also your favorite person yeah i
don't
i don't really know i feel very happy
that makes me yeah i'm like giddy for
you thank you
is it is it weird or is it more exciting
now to like be on set with him and are
there sort of rules in place
of there's no fighting on set yeah i
think we definitely have
boundaries i think because we were
friends before this
and you know we we understood how we
worked
as individuals before we were seeing
each other
we knew how we worked professionally and
like we knew what
each other's personal boundaries were
for certain things and
and so like you know just as a rule like
you know we never bring
anything negatively
to said if you know say there's like i
don't know disagreement or whatever like
or you know if if there's a conversation
that needs to be had that could
potentially
like you know kind of rain on you know
his parade for that day
or whatever like that's never something
that happens before work
and it's also one of those things too
when we go to set and
something i really appreciate as we go
to set we are individuals
and we are still at the very
minimum we are best friends and we are
partners and we are screen partners so
we're there to support each other
and sometimes you give that person space
sometimes you go and you pull them aside
and you talk with them through they've
had a difficult scene and they need to
download or whatever it's whatever your
partner needs at the time and i really
really
love that and respect that about him and
our relationship
what's that well let's talk about this
movie it's called the giant
yes i thought it was creepy
dark gritty yeah psychological
what kind of drew you to the project as
you were reading
the script it was exactly that it was
creepy
and it was psychological it was a real
mind twister
it was a real page turner because i just
didn't know what was going to be next
and
um i love films like that i love films
that really
leave you thinking for a couple days
afterwards like you just can't get it
out of your head
the script was very uh visceral in that
like there was lots of descriptives
about
the kudzu and the cicadas and
and that all felt like home so it was
like this weird
paradox of like creepy and you know the
fear of the unknown but also
homes for your fans out there who love
outer banks
how would you describe this movie to
them what would you tell them it's about
oh geez it's like a psychological
horror thriller but also coming of age
in a way without our banks it's it's
like this
best summer of your life feel good type
mystery
treasure hunt um and then with this it's
like
kind of it's gritty it kind of messes
with your head which
and um i really like that um that's
that's something i enjoy
watching and i would hope that you know
it's i know it's not for everyone
but it's it's definitely it's still
coming of age it's just maybe more the
grittier side
to it if you like it if you like a
mind twister you'll like it